I think it's time to move past simple
cosmetic changes to the site so far
you've used media queries to change
simple things like background color and
whatnot but you can also use media
queries to change the entire layout of
the page in fact this is how developers
accomplished responsive design by using
media queries like min width and max
width developers can change the entire
layout of the page right the point at
which the page changes layout is called
a break point and depending on how your
site is laid out you might have one or
several break points you know what let's
take a look at a few examples of pages
using break points afterwards I'll show
you a few more pages and you tell me how
many break points they've used